[Music]
good first of all thank you for coming
in for the studio at WonderCon super
appreciate it I have to I guess the big
thing I want to know is we're at
WonderCon slash comic-con what's the
thing that if you could walk the
convention floor right now that you
would want to like geek out over or go
by I don't know what's here watch the
Dark Phoenix panel like in the crowd and
the crowd right exactly I understand
that they actually have a lot of cool
stuff on sale downstairs on the floor
you should wear like a you know
stormtrooper helmet and just walk
because I think yeah I like all the
costumes I saw a really good
Nightcrawler
oh you did yeah I can't wait to see all
the costumes that's my favorite yeah for
in a really furry long Wow
yeah it's really I know you guys don't
at the time but it's really worth
walking around it's a lot of fun I want
to do that and I also want to go on some
of the rides at Disneyland
oh yeah that's I think we should skip
lunch and go on some rides Tower of
Terror oh let's do that okay it's funny
you mentioned that I am gonna get into
Dark Phoenix but I wanted to know
recently Fox and Disney have merged so I
really want to know have you already
asked for a free annual passport now
that you're like interconnected yes it's
a great idea
so the other thing of course is do you
have a favorite ride at Disneyland I've
only been once what what did you I
thought the good I think the Cars Land
is really cool that the whole drum
Radiator Springs I haven't been section
no you see kids they're like flipping
out in there really that's super cool I
like the there's like like a like an
experience yeah the right it's like the
IMAX ride it's we're gonna you're
amazing the chair and you get lifted up
it's 4d yeah it's like yeah like the art
like when you're earned over the orange
grove like it smells like oranges that's
it that's it yeah that's the right I
love that right when did they implement
that I want to say it's been there for a
little while I think
of California you should go check it out
it's really cool when during lunch yeah
let's do it
you know chance you're gonna get there
no jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys today so I've seen the opening like
1215 minutes of the movie which is
awesome and completely different than
the x-men movies that have come before I
wanted to know if you could sort of talk
about what Simon did as a writer
director that may be different than what
people have seen thus far yeah I mean
it's a singular vision and that's
exciting
I think no matter what the scale of the
what saw as the film is you know whether
it's a two hundred million dollar movie
or two hundred thousand dollar movie
like to have a writer director guiding
the way is really nice because there's
there's no there's no conflict between
you know two to two visions so that was
that was really nice what's great about
working with Simon is that if you're
struggling with something through in the
scene like he knows the dialogue in the
you know the context of the narrative
you know so well like the back of his
hand like he knows how to tweak things
and and rework things to make them work
and so I think he's he's good at working
like that and in you know being able to
to to adapt to when you run into certain
issues if you run into any or are you
having problems with you know a certain
line or something so that was nice and
also I think one of the things that
Simon's kind of done with this film is
he's made it a far more character-driven
movie and far more emotional it's kind
of you know how Logan was very different
in style to all of the other kind of
Wolverine x-men movies and it's kind of
the same with this you know Logan was
kind of like a western style and and
this is more of like a family drama
rather than a superhero maybe one of the
things is all these movies have these
huge action set pieces and those are
cool but you really don't care unless
you care about the characters and I love
like the banter between you know that
like you want to see you yes characters
interacting so talk a little bit about
maybe some of like a favorite day on set
filming like those dialogue-driven
scenes if you have one there's a lot of
good there's a lot of good dramatic you
know scenes in this in this movie a lot
of really complex relationships and the
characters and all the conflict because
what happens is you know when Jean Grey
starts to kind of be you know taken over
by this the the Dark Phoenix power I
mean it kind of splits the x-men up into
two groups and so it causes a lot of
conflict between between people and and
I think that's something we've explored
in x-men movies but not to this to this
level and so I think there's a lot of
complexity there so that's you know you
know to speak to your point about the
characters I mean that's something
that's really apparent in this film and
really exciting I'm gonna say talked a
little bit on filming zero-g and how
much fun it is to try to pretend that
you're in zero-g oh it's a lot of fun is
it you that's really good at zero-g I
think it's you yeah Ty's excellent at
zero gravity I'm not so much well I mean
we had I mean it's we had like all these
sliders and and you know that obviously
like wrapped in green so we'd paint them
out but basically like you know one
character is like floating through the
the center of the the spacecraft and and
it was cool it was cool to work with all
to all that stuff I mean it's it's at
times it becomes a little uh you can
almost act as a barrier because thank
you sometimes you you just forget that
you're in zero-g did that happen to you
you like no no I'd never forget on a
zero-g but it was fun it was really cool
I mean I'm excited to see to see how the
entire sequence is it's really cool have
you not seen the space sequence
I always seen I don't think I've seen
the whole thing I don't know no no I've
seen I've seen parts of it I don't think
I've seen the whole thing okay I'll let
you know it's real good
oh that's good it's really good at
convincing zero-g 100% and I think I
don't want us to think Captain Marvel
zero-g
well that's a good question yeah they
did it's a completely different thing
okay completely and also very little bit
climatic no because your sequence I
don't want to spoil anything but your
sequence involves powers and there's a
lot going on it's a completely different
thing you have Quicksilver there's stuff
Quicksilver scenes are always the best
right what but I want it the thing is
though is it there one of the cool
things about that space sequences it's
all of you guys yeah you know working
together and I would imagine it's not
always like that on set so are those
days you're like really looking forward
to a little more when you know it's the
whole team yeah
always I think is like it's so much fun
when all of us get together and we're
all actually genuinely really good
friends and so like it's just we always
just have the best time on that space on
that like x-jet those seas always amaze
fun ya know it's fun because they lot
they have to you basically get locked
locked in because they're like alright
we're putting the side panel on you know
we're gonna do these shots and you're
gonna come out for the next 45 minutes
or something yeah so you'll get like
cabin fever oh yeah those three days
abandon the x-gen we all start playing
never have I ever
we do we do we play never have I ever
three fingers I have so many more
questions to follow up on that but I'm
gonna be good who ruins the most takes
and why oh oh I would say Jen Jennifer
Lawrence yeah this gets thrown right
under the bus
it's it's a I mean she's just happens
you know yeah but that's the great thing
about film you know yeah do it again
none of us would be good stage actors I
definitely know I wouldn't be a terrible
stage actor I know I'm about to run out
of time I just want to ask two three
really fast fun questions what TV show
do you want to guest star on ah Barry
have you seen Barry it's so what else
it's real good cosmos by the way I just
want to go on and like watch them sure
sure Neil Tyson
Degrassi it's like they showed up oh oh
I've never seen
I'm yeah well it's just an interesting
choice that would be great
I don't know is so interesting okay
let's move on to the next one what film
scared you as a kid The Witches Angelica
Houston is the Grand High Priestess
which is all like 90s right 90s and
actually no the year does anyone know
you're witches it's in the nineties
right
Angelica Houston like peels off her face
and she's like this disgusting 20s
wasn't it yeah the 30s I think was late
30s maybe it could be the 20s
one of my last things is there anything
that you guys collect oh it was a big
answer
I collect pictures like when you say
pictures do you mean like a vintage
pictures from like Paris in the 50s or
low I mean like like photos of my family
or like Polaroids or wine corks do you
well only once I've drunk the wine and
then I keep the cork and I remember like
oh that was a good bottle oh and I keep
it I actually do the same thing and the
cork Haley I really do and the cork will
usually have the brand so that's a
popular thing too I would know if it's
popular but but we I do it you both do
it and there's like a jar yeah you know
but that's a whole nother thing and
fingernails
right um I got I got a I have a million
other things but we can talk on another
time I'm just gonna say thank you so
much for coming in thank you really
appreciate it and I really can't wait to
see the finished film